okay good morning everyone
this is Jack Van Horn from the bd2k
training coordinating Center at the
University of in California and I'd like
to welcome you all to our it's a
knowledge guide to the fundamentals of
data science today we're gonna be
hearing from Daniella Witten from the
University of Washington in Seattle on
the subject of supervised machine
learning dr. Whitten had earned her
bachelor's degree in math and biology
with honors and distinction from
Stanford University in 2005 and then
earned her PhD in statistics from
Stanford in 2010 since 2014 Daniela has
been an associate professor in
statistics and biostatistics at the
University of Washington in Seattle her
research involves the development of
statistical machine learning methods for
high dimensional data with applications
to genomics and to other fields she's a
recipient recipients of numerous awards
including an indie sake research
fellowship in NIH directors early
independence award a Sloan research
award and an NSF Career Award her work
has been featured in the popular media
and Forbes magazine Elle magazine on
KUOW radio and as a pop tech science
fellow she is the co-author with Gareth
Gareth James Trevor hasty and Rob Tim
Tim shirani
of the very popular text introduction to
statistical learning she was a member of
the Institute of Medicine committee that
released the report on the evolution of
translational omics so her talk today
will be very appropriate to the subject
of big data computing and statistical
learning again I'd like to remind you
that if you have any questions for dr.
Whitten during her talk to please submit
your questions by the little questions
submission mechanism here on the right
side usually on the right side of your
display and we'll gather all those up
and ask them at the end of dr. Whitman's
presentation so without further ado dr.
Whitten thank you very much for
presenting to us today
thanks so much for the introduction and
so today as we just heard I'm going to
talk about supervised machine learning
and just to give you an overview machine
learning basically falls into two camps
supervised learning and also
unsupervised learning so the idea behind
supervised learning is that we use a
data set X to predict or to detect an
association with a response Y so
examples of supervised learning and
include regression where we're trying to
predict a quantitative response
classification where we're trying to
predict a categorical response and
you're going to hear a lot about
supervised learning today from me but I
do briefly just want to mention that the
other big type of machine learning is
unsupervised learning and the idea
behind unsupervised learning is that we
want to discover the signal in a matrix
X and know Y is available so
unsupervised learning is an incredibly
important topic and that's actually
going to be covered in next week's
webinar and today instead I will just be
focusing on supervised learning so
there's a couple different flavors of
supervised learning and maybe the
best-known flavor is regression so the
idea behind regression is on that you
want to predict a quantitative response
such as blood pressure cholesterol level
tumor size so the thing that makes
regression regression is that the
response which I'm going to call why
today is quantitative so the other main
flavor of supervised learning is
classification and in classification we
are trying to predict a categorical
response such as on tumor versus normal
tissue heart disease versus no heart
disease subtype of disease and so on so
the only difference between regression
and classification is the type of your
response Y if it's a quantitative
response you're in the regression
framework if it's a categorical or a
qualitative response you
in the classification framework and one
thing that I really want to emphasize is
that it doesn't matter what type of data
matrix X you have so so as I'll mention
in a couple minutes the idea is you have
a data matrix X which contains
measurements for your variables or your
features you're trying to predict this
response Y so I don't care if your data
matrix X is quantitative if it's
categorical it doesn't matter it's it's
still going to be regression if your
response Y is quantitative and it will
still be classification if your response
Y is categorical so regression and
classification are the two main flavors
of supervised learning there are also
other flavors like if you have a
response that's a survival time which is
possibly censored because I'm you know
some people might have died or dropped
out of the study and so on then that is
a slightly different flavor of
supervised learning but the main ideas
that apply to regression also hold for
these other flavors of supervised
learning and so today I'm going to just
be talking about regression but again
all of these ideas extend directly to
other types of quantitative responses so
I'm going to start off talking about
linear models because linear models give
us an incredibly flexible framework for
doing regression and basically if you're
doing supervised machine learning 90% of
what you need fits within the linear
model framework and then at the end of
my talk I'm going to just speak for a
few minutes about a really different
type of of supervised learning which is
a decision tree approach so to begin
we're in the linear model setting and
the idea is that we have n observations
and for the iPod servation I'm going to
call the response Y sub I and I'm going
to let X I won through xip
denote the P features for that I thought
provision so for example Y I might
blood pressure which is a quantitative
value and then XY 1 through X IP are a
bunch of features maybe these are
biomarkers that we think are predictive
of blood pressure so we want to use
these features to predict the response
and in a linear model we do this as
follows we say that Y I is just equal to
intercept beta naught plus a coefficient
beta 1 which gets multiplied by the
first feature X I 1 and so on all the
way through to the peak feature where
beta P is multiplied by X IP plus a
noise term epsilon so epsilon sub I is
the noise term associated with the i'f
observation and the idea is that we need
to estimate these unknown coefficients
beta naught through beta P I'm in other
words we have to fit the model so
actually there's a lot of ways we could
fit this model and I'm going to start by
talking about the best known way to fit
this model and then I'll talk about the
fact that that best known way isn't
necessarily the best approach especially
in the context of biomedical big data
but first let's talk about the simplest
way to fit a linear model and if you
took dot 101 then you probably saw the
least squares approach for fitting a
linear model and the idea behind least
squares is that we look for estimates of
the coefficients I'm going to if you see
a little hat on a coefficient that means
it's an estimate so I'm looking for a
beta naught hat beta 1 hat all the way
through to beta P hat such that the sum
of squared errors is as small as
possible so I'm going to sum the
quantity Y I - the the prediction or the
fitted value from my model I get that by
plugging in the coefficient estimates
and then I'm going to square that
quantity so this entire term here is
called a sum of squared errors it's also
called a residual sum of squares and
when I fit a model using these squares
I'm just looking for these coefficient
estimates such that this residual sum of
squares is as small as possible
your way to represent this is to say
that I'm just looking for coefficient
estimates such that the sum of Y I minus
y I hat squared is as small as possible
where Y I hat is the prediction from my
model or rather or you can also call it
the fitted value from the model so this
is a really natural way to to fit a
linear model and it works pretty well
especially sort of in the old-fashioned
data settings where you have three or
five or eight variables that you've
measured and you have a huge number of
observations so this works really well
if n is large and P is really small but
as we'll see in a few minutes
often in the context of biomedical big
data least squares is not the best way
to go but before I get there I'm here's
a picture showing what least squares is
they're actually doing so here's an
example with the response Y and two
predictors X 1 and X 2 so the
observations are shown as red circles
and the least squares fit to the data is
a plane it's that green blue plane that
you see in the middle here and the
reason that this is a plane is because
we have two features so instead of a
least squares line we have a least
squares claim and these black vertical
bars here they tell us how far why I is
from the prediction for y I with our
model so in other words this this black
vertical bar tells me at a distance Y I
minus y I hat and so this this blue
least squares plane is actually exactly
positioned such that the sum of Y I
minus y I have squared is as small as
possible in other words so that the sum
of squared black lines is as small as
possible and you can sort of imagine
that if you shifted the plane up or down
or if you wiggled it a little bit now
then the sum of squared black lines
would actually increase so okay you've
probably seen least squares regression
before this is something that comes up
like in a classical statistics class but
I want to talk now a little bit about
the machine learning perspective on what
we're doing so in machine
when we talk about fitting a model we
say that we're fitting a model on a
training set so the training set refers
to the data that you use to actually fit
your model and given that we fit a model
on the training set we can think about
the error of our model on the training
set usually we we think about the the
mean squared error and you've actually
seen this before this is just 1 over n
times that residual sum of squares
quantity that we saw a couple slides ago
so remember the way that we chose the
coefficients beta naught hat beta 1 hat
3 beta P hat was actually just to make
this quantity as small as possible so we
basically are guaranteed that the mean
squared error is going to be decently
small on the training set because we we
literally chose these coefficient
estimates in order to make this mean
squared error small but what I'm trying
to emphasize here is that this mean
squared error right now what I'm showing
you is the mean squared error calculated
on the training set and moving forward
I'm going to call this the training
error so this mean squared error it
gives me a representation of how good my
model is on the data that I use to fit
my model it does not give me an idea of
how good my model would be
hypothetically on data that I did not
use to fit my model I'm so like if
you're familiar with r-squared from a
linear model an r-squared is just really
closely related to the training error
when your r-squared is big your training
error is small there's really actually a
one-to-one mapping between those two
quantities so it turns out
training error and equivalently
r-squared are not a great way to think
about how good your model is and the
reason that they're not good is because
there will always improve as we fit a
more complex model so like imagine that
first you fit a model with with three
variables and you calculate your your
training error and then you say hey
actually maybe I should just add in one
more Mont one more variable to my model
well your training error is gonna go
down it's literally guaranteed to go
down or maybe stay the same as you
increase more as you increase the number
of variables so training error we can
see right away there's kind of a problem
because it's going to look better and
better and better as we add more and
more variables to our model and the
problem basically is that training error
quantifies the fit to the training data
so as you fit a more and more complex
model to the training data your model is
going to look better and better on the
training data actually to the point
where if you fit a complex enough model
we can get a perfect fit to the training
data with zero error but the problem
here is that what we really care about
is the models performance not on the
training data but rather on a test set
so for me a model is good not if it
accurately describes the training data
but actually if it accurately describes
the test set because I don't really care
about predicting the response on the
data that I already collected because I
know the response on the data that I
already collected what I care about is
predicting the response on a new
observation for which the response is
unknown that was not part of my training
set so like if you're you know coming up
with some way to predict survival time
on the basis of gene expression among
patients with some disease like I
already know the survival time for the
patients that I'm using to fit my model
so doing a really great job predicting
the survival time for the patients who
are in my training set is really not
useful but what I need to do is do a
really good job predicting survival time
for a new patient who walks into my
clinic tomorrow or next week and that's
really
the idea behind the fact that the
training error is getting at the wrong
quantity instead I need to be getting at
the models performance on a test set so
just to reiterate as we fit a more
complex model on in particular as we
increase the number of variables the
r-squared of our linear model will
always increase and the training error
will always decrease so that's that's
just really important to realize because
it gives us an idea of the fact that
training error and r-squared are telling
us the wrong thing so as I mentioned
what we care about is the performance of
a model on observations not used to fit
the model and to quantify this a little
bit more what I really care about is the
difference between on the response for a
test observation and the prediction for
test observation where here Y hat test
is the predicted value or the fitted
value that I'm going to get if I get a
new test observation and I plug the
variables for that test observation into
the model that I fit on the training set
so the test error is the average of Y
test minus y hat test squared over a
bunch of test observations and what I
really want is a model for which the
test error is small and so we
I saw the first two panels of this plot
showing that as the complexity of your
model increases the r-squared will
increase and the training error will
decrease but the really critical thing
here is that the test error is not going
to continue to decrease as you make your
model more and more complex actually the
test error is going to bottom out for
some certain level of model complexity
which is indicated here using a red
arrow and after it bottoms out it's
going to start increasing so you can see
that in terms of test error you don't
just want to fit an arbitrarily complex
model in order to make the test error
small there's going to be some
intermediate level of model complexity
and actually if you take one thing out
of this webinar it should be this figure
it should be an understanding of the
fact that the only thing that matters is
test error training error is just not
relevant and if you if you focus on
fitting your supervisor machine learning
models in order to make your in order to
make the type training error small then
you've just totally missed the boat
because you'll end up over here with the
tiny training error but a really
substantial test error so I just want to
try to illustrate the problem with
thinking about training error in an in a
small example so what I'm showing here
is just a small on the left is just a
small simulated dataset with a single
feature X on the horizontal axis and the
single response Y on the vertical axis
and the observations are shown in red
and on the left is what you get if you
just fiddle least-squares linear model
tipitina
so in this example there's like 20
observations one feature I fit up a
linear model to the data and using least
squares and what I can see is that
there's clearly like a non zero training
error here because these red points
aren't exactly on the black least
squares line so the training error is
nonzero but this looks like a pretty
good model I can imagine that if I had a
a test set like if I were able to
generate more observations from the same
distribution that gave me the red
observations
the test error would be like pretty
modest this is a pretty decent fit to
the data but now in contrast let's look
over here on the right so on their right
it's the exact same setup but now
instead of having two instead of having
20 observations like we had on the left
we just have two observations on the
right and I'm again just fitting a
linear model just with one variable X
but what I see now is that I got a
perfect fit to this training day so my
training error on the right is zero so
we look at this picture on the right and
we see that I got zero training error
but this model on the right it does not
sit well right this is this model
doesn't look good and if we imagine
generating more observations from the
same distribution the this we see this
actually is a really bad model those
additional observations would would
actually be nowhere close to this black
line because we over fit the data here
we fit a model that was too complex
given the amount of data with only two
observations you actually can't fit a
linear model in a meaningful way so over
here on the right we got zero training
error but the test error would actually
be huge um so this is kind of just an
intuitive explanation of the fact that
training error is not the right thing to
be looking at because like on the right
here the training error is zero but we'd
get a really big test error and this is
also an example on the right of the fact
that even something that seems really
simple like a least squares linear model
can actually be too complex for the data
and in a little example with just two
observations okay so one thing that I
just keep on referring to offhand is
this notion of model complexity model
complexity is actually central to
absolutely everything in supervised
learning as model complexity increases
training error will decrease and I've
kind of offhand been talking about you
know how we can increase the number of
variables in our model and then the
model will get more complex but actually
the notion of model complexity is much
more general than just the number of
variables in the model
and we're actually going to see in a few
minutes when we look at Ridge regression
an example of a model that might include
a lot of variables but it's not such a
complex model so in other words if it's
convenient for you to think about model
complexity as like the number of
variables in the model then you should
just remember that that that's one way
you can think about model complexity but
it's often not the best way and and
model complexity actually is is more
general than just the number of
variables in your model okay so as model
complexity increases training error will
decrease but the test error might not I
already said this one okay so just to
explain in a little more detail what's
happening in terms of model complexity
there's really two things we need to
think about when we think about how good
a model is so the first thing is bias so
the bias and beta hat is the average
difference between beta and beta hat if
we were to repeat the experiment a huge
number of times so bias is basically
telling us how good is our model on
average and as we've said an
increasingly complex model the bias is
going to decrease so this is really good
because I have the thing that as we get
a more complex model on average our
model is going to be better and better
and better and that's great because I
want a really good model so that
suggests that I should fit a really
complex model but there's a problem
which is that it turns out I don't just
care about bias I also care about
something called variance and the
problem is and the variance of beta hat
is the amount by which the beta hats
will differ across the experiments so
imagine that I repeated an experiment a
huge number of times and I calculated
beta hat every time so the variance of
data hat is just the amount by which
these estimates of beta would vary
across the experiments and the problem
is that if I fit an increasingly complex
model the variance of beta hat is going
to increase and the test error which is
the thing that I really care about is
actually the square of the bias
plus the variance so the thing that
happens here is that there's a trade-off
between bias and variance because as I
increase the model complexity the
squared bias is going to decrease so
that's really good but the variance is
gonna increase and that's really bad and
so typically if your model complexity is
really really really low your bias is
gonna be huge and your variance is gonna
be small but the sum of something huge
and the sum of something small is still
huge
so that's bad and you fit if you fit a
super complex model the bias is gonna be
really small but the variance will be
huge and again the sum of something
small plus huge is really huge and
typically for some intermediate level of
model complexity you can make both of
these relatively small simultaneously
and that'll make your test error small
and that's the sweet spot so what we
want is a level of model complexity that
makes this sum and consequently the test
error small so in other words we need a
model with small bias and also small
variance so you can see this by a
variance trade-off in a picture model
complexity from low to high is on the x
axis error is on the y axis you can see
training error and blue test error in
red so you can see the training error is
monotone decreasing in model complexity
but the test error is not the smallest
test error is happening right here for
an intermediate level of model
complexity and this figure also shows
you that as you get a more complex model
the bias is decreasing but the variance
is increasing and for a less complex
model the bias is increasing and the
variance is decreasing okay so hopefully
by now you you are on the same page as
me that test set error is the thing that
we care about so if we want to make sure
that we're fitting a model with a small
test center then we need a way to
estimate the test set error and
basically there are three ways that we
can estimate the test error and as
you'll see they're actually all pretty
similar
so the first one is the validation set
approach and the idea behind the
validation set approach is that you
would have your n observations and you
split them into two sexes
I train your model on one set and then
calculate the test error on the other
side so the validation set approach is
great it's very easy to implement the
only problem is that you arbitrarily are
splitting your data into two sets and if
you had done a different split of the
data you might get a slightly different
estimate of test error people don't
really like that so to overcome that
problem we can do an approach called
leave one out cross validation and the
idea behind leave one out cross
validation is that we have our n
observations we fit a model using all
but the first observation so you can see
we're leaving out the first observation
in this top row here fitting a model on
the remaining observations and then
calculate the test error on the first
observation next we fit a model on all
but the second observation and evaluate
the test error on the second observation
and so on we do this n times each time
we fit the model on all but one of the
observations and we test on the
remaining observation then the average
the error rates that we get and that
gives us a really good estimate of the
test error so leave one out cross
validation is really nice it's very
systematic it feels thorough because we
leave out every observation one at a
time but the problem is that often it's
computationally undesirable because we
have to fit end models in order to get
an estimate of our model complexity and
if if n is a really big number like we
have a really big sample size in our
study then this isn't going to fly so
typically the preferred approach is
something called k-fold cross-validation
and here I'm showing you an example of
k-fold cross-validation with K equals 5
and the idea is that we split the
observations into five sets and we're
repeatedly going to train the model on
four sets and evaluate its performance
on the fifth so for example right here
in blue you can see my training set I'm
going to fit the model on the training
set evaluate the test error on this test
set in orange and then I'm going to
repeat but I'm going to be changing each
time which set of observations I'm
considering to be the test set average
those five error rates and that gives us
an estimate of our test error so it's
really up to you how you want to
estimate test error leave one out cross
validation the validation set approach
and k-fold cross-validation are all
perfectly fine the important thing is
that when you fit a model you need to
check what its test error is um because
if you don't want to accidentally come
up with a model that has a great
training error a bit of a very poor test
error okay so so far we've talked about
linear models that we fit using least
squares but as I have alluded to often
least squares regression is not a great
choice of model and this can be
basically happen for two reasons
it could happen because the least
squares model is not complex enough or
because it's too complex so I'm going to
talk in a couple minutes about what we
do if a least squares model is not
complex enough for our data but actually
typically what we see in big biomedical
data is the police squares model is too
complex in the sense that there are too
many features relative to the number of
observations so for example suppose that
I want to predict a patient's response
to chemotherapy and my predictors are
things like the expression levels for a
whole lot of genes maybe for you know
20,000 genes protein levels where I've
acid some huge number of proteins or
maybe just I've done DNA sequencing on
genes that are potentially implicated in
breast cancer so in each of these
situations
chances are we have a huge number of
features or variables that we're using
as predictors in our model and if we fit
a least-squares model in the setting
we're actually going to get really bad
test error our training error would look
awesome but the test
error would be really bad because we'd
be overfitting the data so if we fit a
model that's too complex
then that's known as overfitting
basically a model that has a low
training error but a high test error is
a lot all that we've over fit to the
data
so typically least squares is going to
over fit the data in the context of big
biomedical data and so what we need is
an alternative to least squares we need
a way to fit a linear model but somehow
get less complexity than we'd get if we
fit least squares using the P variables
so Ridge regression and the lasso are
our two methods for fitting a linear
model that are alternatives to least
squares and they yield a less complex
model by shrinking the regression
coefficients and so as we're going to
see these are really just minor
modifications to the least squares
fitting approach but they can give us
much better results in case in cases
when least squares it's too complex of
the model so Ridge regression and the
lasso are examples of what are known as
regularization approaches or
penalization approaches um and there are
many other examples of such methods but
I'm just going to focus on Ridge
regression and the lasso today
because those are the two best known
approaches I also just wanna mention
that these regularization approaches are
actually a topic of extensive
contemporary research and statistical
machine learning today okay so first of
all Ridge regression
the idea behind Ridge regression is that
we're looking for coefficients beta
naught through beta P that mentum eyes a
residual sum of squares so this is just
like what we had in the least squares
setting but also there's an additional
term here which is a tuning parameter
lambda times the sum over the features
of beta J squared so again
is just like the least-squares
optimization problem except that now
there is an additional term and so here
lambda is a non-negative tuning
parameter and we can see right away that
if lambda is zero then this term just
disappears and we're just fitting a
least-squares model but as we increase
lambda this term is going to tend to
decrease the sum of theta J has
Squared's is going to decrease and
basically the way that you can think
about it is that there are two terms
this first term quantifies how well I'm
fitting the training data and this term
quantifies how complex my model is you
can actually think of some of beta J
squared as it as a way to quantify your
model complexity so when lambda is
really smaller when lambda 0 I'm just
focusing on getting a really good fit to
the training data with this loss term
but when lambdas bigger I'm going to be
focusing more on getting a really simple
model or a model that's not too complex
with this penalty term and actually in
the limit when lambda becomes
arbitrarily large you can see that these
beta J's are going to actually approach
0 because you know if if lambda is just
super huge then you're going to want
your sum of beta J Squared's to be
really tiny so that this penalty term
doesn't get too big so you can see that
on that lambda really controls the
complexity of your model when lambdas
really bigger again it got a really
really really simple model with just
tiny coefficient estimates so this plot
gives you a graph
representation of what Ridge regression
gives you as you vary the changing
parameter lambda so here I'm showing
lambda on the x-axis the y-axis shows
coefficients and this is a little I'm
example dataset with a bunch of features
most of which are small and those are
shown in gray and then for features that
are larger are shown in various colors
so in order to understand this figure
like take a look over here
oops all the way on the left side where
my cursor is so lambda is around 0.01
here and when lambda is 0.01 like the
black coefficient is around negative 280
the red one's around 420 but as I
increase lambda for example as I make
lambda equal to one right here the black
coefficient is slightly smaller the red
coefficient slightly smaller okay
these coefficients are slightly smaller
and as I make lambda really big take a
look over here like when lambdas 100 now
all the coefficients are quite a bit
smaller and over here where lambda is
10,000 all the coefficients are really
close to 0 so when we perform Ridge
regression results are actually a
function of this tuning parameter lambda
and if you want to know what would
happen with a given value of lambda you
just go to that position on the x-axis
and you you look at the value of the
coefficients for that particular lambda
so over here we're fitting a really
simple model with very low variance
because all the coefficients are 0
that's very low variance but it's going
to have big bias
so overall the test error is going to be
really big over here probably the test
error is going to be big also because
this model has low bias but high
variance over here and over here things
are more intermediate so probably
the best value of the test error is
going to be around here but in order to
find out we'd have to use one of the
approaches that I mentioned earlier for
estimating the test error so one thing
that I want you to notice is that over
here when lamp is really big
all those coefficients become very close
to zero but they're actually not exactly
zero maybe they're like 10 to the
negative 3 or something we can't quite
see in the figure but but none of the
coefficients are exactly zero they're
just becoming closer and closer to zero
so in practice when you're performing
Ridge regression you're going to choose
the tuning parameter use in order to
minimize the test error and then value
the value of lambda that we want is the
one with the smallest test error and
then we would run Ridge regression on
the full data using that same value of
lambda so what I mean by this is like
suppose you're choosing the ballot
you're choosing lamda using the
validations that approach so you fit fit
the model on half of the observations
for a bunch of values of lambda evaluate
each of those models on the other half
of the observations identify the value
of lamda that gave you the smallest
error rate and now using that value of
lamda you need to rerun rich regression
on all of the observations so the
important thing to know about Ridge
regression is that while it can give us
a model that's not very complex when
lambda is large that final model is
going to contain all of the variables no
matter what um and sometimes this is
undesirable
so like imagine that you're trying to
come up with a way to use gene
expression values to predict a patient's
survival time you might want to develop
that model using all 20,000 genes but at
the end of the day you might want your
final model to only involve your handful
of chickens because a final model
involving just a handful of genes would
be easier to like translate into
clinical practice for example it would
be less expensive to come up with a
diagnostic involving just 20 genes
rather than a diagnostic involving
20,000 genes so if we want to fit a
model that involves just a subset of the
features then Ridge regression isn't
gonna take us there so instead we can do
what's called the lasso and the lasso is
just a small tweak to Ridge regression
it gives us a model with mostly 0
elements so in other words the resulting
model is sparse and another way to
phrase this is we can say that the lasso
performs feature selection so this is
the optimization problem for the lasso
we're going to look for coefficients
that minimize once again this residual
sum of squares term that by now you've
seen a lot of times plus a penalty um
this looks just like the ridge
regression penalty with just one
difference I'm in Ridge regression we
had a beta J squared term here now I've
got an absolute value of beta J and this
is a really small difference and it
seems like it shouldn't matter but
actually the difference is small that
important because whereas Ridge
regression never gives you any
coefficient estimates exactly equal to 0
the lasso will so like retrogression
we've got this tuning parameter lambda
that controls model complexity when
lambda equals 0 we're just back at least
squares but most importantly for an
intermediate value of lambda we can
actually get some coefficient estimates
that are exactly equal to 0 and that's
the whole reason to ever do the lasso is
if you want coefficient estimates that
are exactly 0 in other words if you want
to sparse model so when lambda is very
large some of the beta J hats will be
exactly 0 in contrast to Ridge
regression where the best you'll ever
see is that some of the beta J hats
might be close to 0 so we thought
like this for regression and now here's
the same figure for the lasso and what I
want you to notice here is like for
example check out what happens when
lambda is 500 so lambda equals 500 the
black coefficient is nonzero
the yellow red and blue ones are nonzero
but all of these gray coefficients have
estimates that are exactly zero so right
here with lambda equals 500 my lasso
model only involves four features so
this is really nice because it means
that if I again if I'm trying to develop
a predictor of response to chemotherapy
my my predictive model here only
involves four of my 20,000 features and
that's pretty great in a lot of settings
um if in said I had lambda equals 5,000
now I have a fitted model that only
involves the blue feature all the other
features are exactly zero so again as we
saw with regression I've got to choose
this parameter lambda the way that I
typically would choose it would be based
on estimating estimating the test error
using one of those approaches that we
saw a few minutes ago and that would
tell us what value of lambda to use but
for example if it if it told if that
approach told us to choose lambda over
here then our final model would involve
only four features okay so that's it for
Ridge regression in the lasso I wanted
just briefly I'm very fast mention
another approach for fitting a linear
model that you may have heard of and
this is called principal components
regression and it's really a different
take on on how we can fit a less complex
model than what we get using these
squares so the idea behind principal
components regression is as usual we
have n observations and P features what
that means is that our observations live
in a p dimensional space but it turns
out that not all those dimensions are
equally useful so for example some of
the dimensions might be completely
redundant with each other and that would
be the case if our features are highly
correlated other dimensions might be
uninformative and that would of course
want to noise features so the question
can we find a low dimensional
representation of the variables that
captures most of the action so instead
of having to deal with P dimensions can
we actually just find em dimensions that
do a pretty good job of capturing what's
happening in the data so so this is um
broadly referred to as a dimension
reduction approach there are a lot of
dimension reduction approaches out there
the two best known such approaches are
principal components regression and
partially squares and right now I'm just
going to mention principal components
regression but if you've heard of
partially squares then it's a similar
type of approach so the idea behind
principal components regression is that
I'm going to look for variables that
I'll call z1 through Zn and these are
linear combinations of my original P
predictors so in other words I'm looking
for coefficients vmj such that ZM is
just a linear combination of the X's and
then once I've identified these new
dimensions the 1 through em I'm just
gonna fit a least squares model but
instead of fitting in the model using my
original features I'm gonna fit the
model with my new features z10 ZM so
this is really simple I'm just telling
you
Julie squares to don't use the original
features and use new features okay well
what are these new features supposed to
be well these new features should be the
principal components of the data so I'm
telling you to take the first M
principal components of your data fiddle
Lee squares model using those as
features and you're done
you just did principal components
regression okay so what are principal
components well you're going to see
these in more detail next week in the
webinar on unsupervised learning but the
idea behind principal components is that
there are linear combinations of your
variables that contain as much
variability of your data as possible so
they're they're basically just a low
dimensional representation of your data
they've captures as much of the
variability
as possible so in an example with two
variables and observations shown in
purple this green line represents the
first principal component and you can
see the first principal component is
sort of the direction along which your
data there is the most so if I had to
summarize these purple observations in
just one dimension then this green line
would give me the best possible summary
so the idea is when you do principal
components regression you're actually
getting a model that's linear in the
original predictors so it is a linear
model and the original predictors but
it's not the same as the least squares
model that you get if you ran these
squares on the original predictors
you're actually getting a much less
complex model provided that M is less
than P um it's important to know that
principal components regression doesn't
involve future selection in the sense
that all of the original predictors are
involved in your final model the number
of principal components that you have
controls model complexity so if M equals
P you're just back at least squares M if
M is smaller than P you're going to get
a less complex model and as usual we're
going to decide on the level of model
complexity by minimizing the test error
okay and then just as an aside principal
components regression is actually very
very similar to Ridge regression in
terms of the underlying mathematics and
PCR works well in a lot of settings but
sometimes it fails and really the reason
for this is because there's no guarantee
that the first M principal components
will explain a lot of or will be
predictive of the response because the
first M principal components will
definitely explain a lot of the
variation in the features but they might
not be predictive of the response okay
so this whole discussion of Ridge
regression the lasso and principal
components regression have focused on
giving you a model that's less complex
than Li squared and again that's because
in the case of biomedical big data
usually least squares is too complex of
the model and the Sen
that you don't have enough observations
and you have a huge number of features
but if it turns out that you're actually
in a setting where you want a more
complex model like maybe you've just
measured a dozen features and you have
twenty thousand observations then don't
worry I'm Lee squares has got you
covered
you can just fit a least squares model
oops I'm sorry this is a typo it should
say we can fit a linear model using
transformations of your features so if
you want to UM you could perform Lee
squares using features X J XJ square at
XJ cubed e to the X J you could even
take products of your features like X J
with X K and so on and in order to fit
the model you could use least squares or
you could actually perform Ridge lasso
and so on so it's always easy to make a
model more complex by just throwing in
new features or combinations or
transformations of your old features um
and that's why I haven't really focused
on how to get a more complex model
because typically that's a pretty easy
task
just remember that if you're considering
a complex model you've got to estimate
your test error
okay briefly on I've been talking about
regression classification is when you
have a categorical or a qualitative
response and the reason I haven't talked
about classification is because it's
easy everything that I've talked about
for regression it implies exactly the
same way to classification so once you
get it with regression you're going to
understand classification - all of the
same ideas apply ok well I'm really
almost out of time but I just want to
spend two minutes talking about a fun
topic which is decision trees so
everything that I've mentioned so far is
within the framework of a linear model
but of course there's other ways you can
do a supervised learning - and a really
fun one is a decision tree so the idea
behind a decision tree is that you are
going to partition the range of X into
boxes and then you're going to make a
prediction within each box so decision
tree models are variant
furball and show you how interpretable
it is we can look at an example so this
is just a toy dataset and what we're
gonna do is predict a baseball players
salary based on various characteristics
so here's a regression tree for this
baseball dataset and so here's how you
read it you start at the top and you say
all right if I've been playing if this
player has been playing baseball for
less than four and a half years we're
gonna go to the left and if they've been
playing for more than a four and a half
years we're gonna go to the right so
whenever there's a branch or whenever
there's a split rather if the answer is
yes you're going to go to the left and
if it's no you'll go to the right so
let's say that there is a player who's
been playing for less than four and a
half years okay we're gonna go down to
the left and this if this player batted
in fewer than 60 runs last season we're
gonna go to the left again if they had
more than 80 to put out so we're gonna
go to the right all right now we've got
a check have they been playing for for
more than or fewer than three and a half
years and if they've been playing for
more than three and a half years then my
prediction of their salary is five point
one eight three so this is actually on
the log scale and it's in thousands of
dollars so to figure out how many
dollars this is multiplied or rather
take it calculate e to the 5 point 183
and then multiply by 1,000 and the
reason that this is on the log scale is
just because it's better to model salary
on a log scale than on a linear scale
um so alternatively if if the player who
you want to pick salary for has played
for more than four and a half years and
they did more than 118 or 117 and a half
hits last season and fewer than fifty
two and a half walks then they actually
are going to have substantially higher
salary you need to the six point five
four nine thousands of dollars per year
so regression trees are are really great
because you don't need to know any math
you don't need a computer to understand
them you can like imagine you're working
in an emergency room and there might
just be some regression tree and this
can just be like you know pasted it on
the wall at the nurse's station and
gives the nurses like a really quick way
to just look look up at patient's
characteristics and then get the
prediction that they need so decision
trees are interpreted the whole reason
to ever use a decision tree is because
you want a picture like this because you
want something like this that you can
show to someone who's who either doesn't
want to have to like figure out all the
maps or just doesn't have time and they
need something quick that they can look
at regression trees typically are not as
interpret or are not as accurate as
other approaches to supervised learning
but they are interpretable so if you
care about interpretability then great
and if you don't care about
interpretability
this is not a good choice because you
can do better in terms of accuracy using
other methods um so I just want to show
in a little more detail on how do we get
this tree well suppose that our only
variables were the number of hits last
season and the number of years that the
player's been playing so what we do is
we partition feature space in a very
particular way in order to get these
three regions r1 r3 and r2 and then to
get the prediction within the region r1
we just take the average of the
observations in this region to get the
prediction within our three we average
those observations and to get the
prediction within this region we average
those observations and that gives us a
tree that looks like this where the
number reported here is the average
within the regions r1 r2 and r3 okay so
when you're building a decision tree you
can decide how big you want your tree to
be a large tree is going to tend to
overfit the data a small tree is going
to under fit the data and we typically
want to use the test error in order to
determine what's the best tree size so
for example on the baseball data on the
Left we have a really big tree on the
right we have a much smaller tree the
one on the left is going to have low
bias but high variance the one on the
right is going to have low variance but
possibly high bias and the way that we
would choose which tree we want is is by
estimating
test error okay so I just want to close
with a couple of maybe one final comment
which I don't have time to go into
detail but this comment is basically
that it doesn't matter how fancy the
machine learning is that you're doing
you always have to think about just the
underlying science and the experimental
design and a particular one really big
problem that we see within the context
of big biomedical data is issues called
batch effects and batch effects can
occur if there's some kind of
variability in your data that results
from non biological factors batch
effects are a huge problem in in
biological data and there's only so much
that you can do in order to deal with
them in order to avoid I'm having batch
effects and validate your results it's
really important to have good
experimental design so you should
randomize your sample run times for
example you don't want to run the cases
first and then the controls you should
try to avoid having batch effects in the
first place by reducing the extraneous
sources of variation in your experiment
typically it's better if when you fit a
model you fit the model on multiple data
sets collected in different labs through
different institutions rather than on a
single data set and really most
importantly it's really important that
you validate any results that you get on
independent data that's collected in a
different lab or in a different
institution because otherwise the
presence of batch effects in your data
could make your results look really good
even your test era could look really
good but if you had a valuated test
error on an independent data phat it
might not look so good okay and
finally the last thing I want to say is
if you're doing supervised machine
learning there's no best approach
there's a lot of ways you can do it I've
talked about a number of methods for
supervised machine learning but there's
literally text books that are just
filled with supervised machine learning
approaches but what I want to emphasize
is that there's no best way sometimes
one approach is going to work better
than another and and so we can't say
that one approach is best but we can say
that some approaches are wrong
so for example you could calculate you
could do cross-validation wrong and then
your test error estimate would be wrong
and you'd be choosing a really bad model
so no approach is best but some
approaches are wrong and if you get one
thing from this lecture the thing that
you get is should be that test error is
really important and if you've got to
make sure that you're calculating it
right because a model that has a high
test error is just really meaningless
they're not useful in actually in any
context okay great
it looks like I'm out of time that's it
and I'm happy to answer questions thank
you so much Daniel that was really a
great overview of statistical learning
supervised in contrast to what we'll
hear about next week I think one of the
themes that ran through your
presentation was really how with our
modeling techniques we struggle with
that curse of dimensionality and we've
had a series of questions about
basically relating to this is there an
assumption with all the dimensionality
that we have in the complexity of these
models that the underlying
distributional properties are normally
distributed in Gaussian or how much can
we deviate from that and still be able
to get to get good estimates yeah okay
so um guess the entity is typically like
not a huge issue in my opinion um so
like if you took your intro stats class
and you learned about linear models you
probably were told that you should
assume that the errors are normal
normally distributed and it turns out
like that's just not a huge assumption
it's not a big deal if your errors
aren't normal
we fine as long as you have a big sample
size but where you really run into
trouble is when your sample size is
small relative to the number of features
you have or relative to the amount of
complexity of the model you're trying to
fit and if if your model is just too
complex for the available data it
doesn't matter what distribution your
data has you're just in trouble so the
bottom line is that model complexity is
incredibly important in that question
you you use the phrase curse of
dimensionality and Chrissa
dimensionality is just a very evocative
phrase to describe this phenomenon that
I've mentioned which is that a more
complex model it can be a curse like if
you measure more variables don't just
assume that more data is better data
because more data just makes you tempted
to have a more complex model and that
can just lead to a high test error so
the bottom line remains you just got to
think about test error more complex is
not better low test error is better
right so I think and a lot of people are
building their models you're
particularly using like a linear
regression based type of a thing and
they look at some sort of a overall
measure of fits or overall amount of
variance accounted for for example they
typically want to look at the overall
statistical significance of that model
like using a an F statistic or something
and the degrees of freedom sort of
capture that model of complexity about
those variables which are in the model
versus those which are part of the error
term how does that act as a governor on
those tests and if that's not still
acceptable are there alternatives like
information based metrics that one could
use as a measure of overall fits that
may be more appropriate right okay
that's a great question
so there were a couple parts to that so
first of all on ok if you want to know
how complex your model is I'm however
you phrase the question I'm always going
to give you the same answer which is the
test error is the best way to figure out
how well your model fits today about how
complex it is because you can you know
there's all kinds of papers about
methods information theoretic methods
and so on but at the end of the day like
if I'm fitting a predictive model what I
want is a model v a test observation
well done there's no there's literally
nothing else that I care about
so trust err is simple it's intuitive
and it gets it what you want I don't
know really I can't think of any example
in the supervised learning context where
you'd care about anything else other
than test error now another question
that was part of that was how can we
actually quantify model complexity mmm
of freedom and as you know if you fit a
linear model using least squares you can
actually just quantify linear complexity
excuse me you can quantify model
complexity by just counting the number
of variables in your model so you fit a
least squares model with ten variables
you used up ten degrees of freedom done
unfortunately as soon as you move away
from least squares to Ridge regression
the lasso principal components
regression decision trees you can no
longer just count up the number of
variables that you're using so a really
good way to see that is in the context
of Ridge regression like Ridge
regression no matter what value of the
training parameter you have you're
always going to be using all P variables
so clearly just counting the number of
variables in your model is not a good
way to quantify model complexity so
model complexity if you wanted to say
like what's the complexity of Model A
versus model B where one is like a
decision tree and one is a lasso model
that's actually really a challenging
thing to quantify and I wouldn't
typically recommend just trying to go
head-to-head between two models and
figuring out which is more or less
complex instead I would again go back to
test error and I would just choose the
model with the lowest test error because
test error is a universal quantity you
can compare across models of very
different types great well we've run out
of time unfortunately I'd like to
encourage everybody who does have
questions for dr. Witt and I'm sure that
uh you can find her her email address it
was on the kind of front of her slide
set there and if you were to write to
her with any questions I'm sure she'd be
delighted to answer
once again thank you dr. Whitten for
giving a great lecture on supervised
statistical learning very appropriate to
big data in a lot of context for our
listeners and once again thank you and
thank you everybody and we'll see you
again next week thank you